Dwyane Wade reached the end of his NBA
career back in 2020 he had faded from
the spotlight during the previous few
years bouncing from Team to team
averaging about 11 points a game towards
the end which isn't great in the NBA for
his position just so you know when he
finally hobbled into retirement he faced
the terrifying Prospect of irrelevance
and it was at this exact moment when
conveniently his 12 year old son came
out as transgender it's very similar
situation to like when Colin Kaepernick
was right at the moment he got benched
he decided to become a social justice
Advocate and for Dwyane Wade right at
the moment when he washed out of the NBA
he decided that he was going to do the
same couldn't have planted any better
really the moment his MBA career ended
he was able to make the jump into the
very profitable business of social
justice activism
in fact his supposedly trans son who he
now calls his daughter
um brought him more attention and
generated more headlines than he was
ever able to achieve on his own even
during his prime playing days
so here's Wade just to just to reminisce
for a moment here's wade back in 2020
announcing his son's new identity to the
World on The Ellen Degeneres Show watch
so once Zaya 12 year old came home and
first Zion everybody I don't know if
everyone knows originally named Zion
Zion born as a boy came home and said
hey uh so I want to talk to you guys
um you know I think going forward I'm
ready to live my truth and I want to be
a referenced as she and her I would love
for you guys to call me Zaya and so
internally now is our job to one go out
and get information to reach out to
every relationship that we have my wife
reached out to everybody on the the cast
of pose we're just trying to figure out
as much information we can to make sure
that we give our child the best
opportunity to be you know her best self
that's his job as a parent he says his
son comes home one day announces that
he's really a girl and his job as a
father he claims is to immediately
accept this statement as fact ask no
follow-up questions uh and follow the
lead of the child blindly and without a
hint of skepticism not only that but the
father's next task is to apparently go
on national television and announce his
12 year old's gender identity to the
entire world this is an important part
of the affirmation process you see not
only do you unquestionably affirm
whatever he says but you also have to
put it on a billboard for the whole
world to see
so that this identity that your child
just adopted five seconds ago will now
be set in stone cemented in place
from this point Wade would go on to
become a prominent advocate of trans
rights and everywhere he went he would
be greeted with Applause and adulation
you know he was just a washed up NBA
player before he was facing a life as a
as an ESPN commentator which is a lowly
fate that anyone would be desperate to
avoid but now with his trans child he
found himself accepted celebrated
beloved in the upper echelons of society
in Hollywood here he is on the red
carpet earlier this year
and I just have to thank you because
you've been amazing with your daughter
it's pretty incredible what keeps you
going fighting for her
um just been you know just being a
father and just seeing my child grow up
every day and doing what she's supposed
to do as a parent is to make sure that
you sit back and you know you see what
it is in life that they want to do and
you try to go there with them and try to
help them mold them into what it is they
want to be and who they want to be so
we're just doing our part you know as
parents and uh we love our kids and we
get to see them every day that's what
people on the outside don't get to see
but we know them and we see them all the
time yeah and we believe them when they
tell us who they are what do you say to
a dad out there whose daughter has just
come home and said I'm trans what do you
say to that Dad well I say the moment
when you were in the hospital when you
grabbed your daughter and you looked at
your daughter and all the things that
went through your mind all emotions that
went through your mind and how much love
fills your heart at that moment don't
let that ever leave you no matter what
like the one thing is parents when we do
is we find our mini me's and we try to
make them just like us we just
understand like our kids are going to be
who they are it's our job to help mold
them and help try to you know push them
in the right places that they want to go
but just remember that moment what you
said in that hospital that day they were
born
yes Dwayne remember that moment in the
hospital when your son was born your son
the doctor identified him by you know by
his sex all human beings are identified
this way and and that's who he was and
that's who he still is so remember that
moment take your own advice at least
that part of your advice the rest of it
is nonsense he says that the job of a
father is to and I quote
sit back and see what they want to do
and go there with them now I'm not
exaggerating when I say that this is the
worst parenting advice I have ever heard
in my entire life
it is quite literally the opposite of
parenting you know a great way to parent
would be to listen to what Dwyane Wade
is saying and just adopt the opposite
approach just do do the reverse of
whatever the hell he is babbling about
because if I parented the way that he
proposes all of my kids would be dead
right now none of them would have made
it past the age of two if I sat back and
went wherever they wanted to go and did
whatever they want to do
if that's how you're going to parent
then you aren't needed you might as well
just abandon your kids in a forest
somewhere let them fend for themselves
maybe they'll be adopted by a friendly
pack of wolves honestly Dwyane Wade's
kids would have been better off Raised
by Wolves than raised by him you know an
actual parent a real parent is there to
offer guidance and wisdom and insight
and Direction and correction that's the
job of a parent that is what you are
there for and if your son comes up to
you one day and reveals that he's
confused about his identity
he is in desperate need of guidance and
wisdom and insight and Direction and
correction
but he wasn't given what he was needed
instead his confusion was Affirmed
and then exploited
and that's certainly the case that the
boy's mother Wade's ex-wife is making
now in court filings from the
post-millennial this was uh breaking
news yesterday it says Wade's ex claims
that Wade has been exploiting ziya Who
quote came out as transgender at the age
of 12. Siobhan funches Wade has now
filed paperwork to ask a judge to hold
off on the legal name change saying that
ziya's modeling contracts and influencer
deals are Wade's impetus for forging
ahead with the gender transition in the
legal filing food just Wade States quote
I have concerns that Dwayne may be
pressuring our child to move forward
with the name and gender change in order
to capitalize on the financial
opportunities that he has received from
companies Wade who has had full custody
since 2011 with the divorce with food
just Wade went through said in August
when petitioning for the name change
that the child's mother was only
informed as a courtesy fuchess Wade
fought for four years to retain custody
of the children she wants ziya to wait
until the age of 18 before making this
change she is the child of both Wade's
oldest children and is concerned that
ziya is being pressured into the changes
by the Elder Wade who is quote poised to
profit from ziya's deals and sex change
to back up her claims function Wade said
that she had a conversation with Wade in
April during which he explained the
extent of the financial benefits of
Zaya's sex change she said quote he told
me that he intended to make our child
very famous due to the name and gender
issue and also informed me that there
would be endorsements and contracts
associated therewith
I am concerned she went on that our
child is being commercialized at a young
age and also is of the uncontrollable
consequences of media exposure I.E cyber
bullying statements and or pictures
taken out of context of our child and
The Unwanted Spotlight focused on our
child
so in other words Dwyane Wade is an
abusive
evil monster and none of this is new in
fact uh the Dwyane Wade case is is quite
instructive
you know it's it's a symptomatic of
something which is like and it raises a
question which is why is it
that celebrities are so prone to having
trans kids have you noticed that how do
you explain the high concentration of
trans kids quote unquote in Hollywood
Dwyane Wade Charlize Theron uh Jamie Lee
Curtis Jennifer Lopez Busy Phillips the
list goes on
it's because uh they use their kids as
status symbols and there is no way
around that conclusion
in fact
even if it happened to be true that a
kid could be quote trans and that their
transgenderism should be affirmed and
both of those things are emphatically
not true at all but even if it was they
would still be totally indefensible to
make your child's gender transition
public
there's no benefit to your child and
turning this into a public spectacle if
he's on a gender Journey as you say and
if you actually wanted to give him space
to be who he is as you claim then you
wouldn't be crowding the space with
cameras and microphones
the only possible effect of the
publicity is to set this new identity in
place
now that you've made them into a leader
right into an LGBT icon and you've got
the endorsement deals rolling in and
there's a lot of money on the line
and not only that but in Dwyane Wade's
son's case like he's making all this
money Dwyane Wade doesn't have a job
anymore and so what now I guess he's the
breadwinner in the family he's going to
feel like he's not able to switch back
or detransition or have a change of
heart
and that of course is exactly why they
do this
they are leading their children it turns
out
you know I wish that Dwyane Wade was
merely sitting back passively and
following his child's lead that would be
bad parenting but not as bad as what
he's actually doing
because what he's actually doing is
actively leading his son
into self-rejection self-loathing
deeper and deeper confusion
he has taken his son by his hand and
guided him straight over the cliff
and profited from it the whole way down
it is again Pure Evil
he should be shamed for it and disgraced
for it
ostracized from society arrested
you know this because this is abuse
but instead all he hears is Applause
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to our members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday have a great weekend
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]